what makes jazz jazz i've always worried  have you got that answered um  yeah i think it's just being cool is it  you reach a certain amount of cool and  then it's jazz you're wearing a suit and  someone comes over to you and says what  are you playing and you kind of go don't  worry about it it's probably jazz it's  probably jazzy it's amazing right i mean  what about you guys what makes jazz jazz  yeah what is jazz is it's spontaneity  it's like creative spontaneity so it's  like everything that's going on we have  like a baseline for what's going to  happen but everything else is improvised  okay when you're on set and you're doing  a scene and you're you go off script  that to me that's jazz it's not right  like someone's saying here this is the  scene  you hear your characters here's the  setting but go be do it how you would do  it right that's the jazz part about it  right  harmonize with me and hold me back all  through the night you're shining bright  i'm your host  [Music]